نقف الى جانب اوكرانيا
قبل وصول الدبابات الغربيه
احتجاجات مستمره في ايران ضد النظام
وتمديدا بالقمع والاعتقالات التعسفيه بحق
المتظاهرين
مشروع قانون امريكي لتمكين البيت الابيض
من حضر تطبيقي توك توك بسبب مساسه بالامن
القومي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الانبار من العربيه قال باتريس
المسؤول عن التواصل باللغه العربيه في
الخارجيه الفرنسيه في تصريحات خاصه
للعربيه
ليس هناك
مانع ليس هناك محظور لكن في معايير طبعا
ثلاثه نقاط مهمه الاولى اننا نريد ان يكون
الدعم او تكون
المسانده فعاله سريعه همم اول شيء
الله تساهم في التصعيد وثا لا تضعف قدرت
فرنسا
روسيا تسابق الزمن لتحقيق مكاسب على الارض
قبل وصول الدبابات الغربيه لاوكرانيا
قالت ان روسيا جعلت مدينه بخموت هدفها
المباشره والرئيسي وتقدمت نحوها بشكل اعمق
وظيفه ان اوكرانيا مع التقدم روسيا امام
خيارين اما مواصله قتال الشوارع الدموي
اول انسحاب للحفاظ على قوتها وعلى مدينه
قبل وصول الدبابات التي يمكن ان تحدث
اختراق في الخطوط الروسيه
اوكرانيا بتزويدها بعشرات العربات المدرعه
بما في ذلك دبابات قتال الرئيسيه اقوى من
نظيرتها الروسيه
هذا هو غلط كله من روسيا اوكرانيا ان
معركه شرسه تهز مدينه اوجيدار التي تحاول
القوات الروسيه دخولها شرق اوكرانيا
بدورها اكدت القوات الانفصاليه المواليه
لروسيا ان وحدات تابعه لها تتحسن على
مشارف المدينه مشيره الى وجود القوات
الروسيه في الجنوب الشرقي وفي شرق المدينه
توجهنا الى المناطق الشماليه الغربيه من
مقاطعه دانيتك المناطق الساخنه جدا نحن
الان على اطراف مدينه مارينكا وهنا في هذا
الاتجاه تدور معارك طاحنه ما بين الطرفين
الروسي والاوكراني وتعتبر هذه المدينه
قريبه جدا من مدينه باخمط التي يسيطر
عليها الجيش الاوكراني ويطوقها الجيش
الروسي من جوانب ثلاثه الناحيه الجنوبيه
والشرقيه والشماليه بعد السيطره على
سوليدار
دخلت قوات وفاكنر من جنوب مدينه باخمت
وبعد وصول المقاتلين الى العمق الاوكراني
من اطراف بلده ايفانكا جنوب المدينه تشهد
المنطقه قتال شوارع بين الطرفين في ذات
الوقت الذي اعلنت فيه كيف انسحابه جيشها
رسميا من مدينه سوليدار المعارك الاعنف
على الطابق الثاني من هذا الموقع هذا هو
مصنع قديم للحليب هذا هو حال المصنع اصبح
ثكن عسكري كبيره للقوات الروسيه اما محوره
مدينه اوغلودار جنوب المقاطعه فيطوق الجيش
الروسي المدينه بنفس استراتيجيه التطويق
مدينه
ويستمر بقصف مراكز الجيش الاوكراني داخل
المدينه مع محاوله اقتحامها من الناحيه
الجنوبيه بعد ان سيطر على طريق السريع
الذي يوصل الامدادات من مدينه بكروكا شمال
غربي
اثبت الفرقه الخاصه في الجيش الروسي لنغطي
عمليه اقتحام اواخر مدينه مارينكا اما
محور روماريكا فما زال يشهدوا معارك
واشتباكات بالاسلحه الخفيفه اضافه الى
القصف المتبادل بين الطرفين مع سيطره
القوات الروسيه على مواقع جديده في الثلث
الاخير من المدينه على الخط الاول من
المواجهه مع الجيش الاوكراني في ذاك الطرف
نرى البنايات المدمره من المدفعيه
والدبابات والقذف وحتى
الاشتباكات بالرشاشات هذه هي المعارك وهذه
هي مدينه ماريكا في مقاطعه دانيت لقناتي
العربيه والحدث رائد الاخضر
ماركه دانيت
في شرق اوكرانيا سلطه الضوء مجددا على
مجموعه بدر التي تقاتل الى جانب القوات
الروسيه مشاركه مؤخرا في الهجوم الروسي
على مناطق في مقاطعه دوناتس بعد معارك
شرسه
وقادها ومولها
روسيا لشبه جزيره القرم عام 2014
كما تقدر واشنطن الى المجموعه تنفق حوالي
100 مليون دولار شهريا في القتال وتتسلم
واسلحه من كوريا الشماليه بينها قنابل
وصواريخ اتهمتها دول الغربيه وخبراء
امويون بارتكاب انتهاكات حقوق الانسان في
دول افريقيا وفي ليبيا وفي مالي ايضا
اظهرت مقاطع فيديو هتافات الليليه في حي
طهران فارس في العاصمه الايرانيه طهران
يرددها متظاهرون غاضبون من النظام والمرشد
خامنئي بسبب اعمال العنف والاعتقال
العشوائي للمتظاهرين لفضل احتجاجات بالقوه
ايه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في مدينه سقف بمحافظه كردستان الايرانيه
ابهرت مقاطع فيديو يضربها النيران في منزل
احد المخبرين الذين يعملون لصالح الامن
الايراني وتسبب في اعتقال عدد كبير من
المتظاهرين
[موسيقى]
قال باتريس باوليه المسؤول عن التواصل
باللغه العربيه في الخارجيه الفرنسيه ان
موقف فرنسا ثابت من الرعايه المعتقلين في
ايران
طهران لهم بانهم جواسيس وشيرا الى انهم
رهائن دوله وعلى ايران الافراج
يوجد ايضا محتجزين من دول اخرى او نحن
بتنسيق في في هذه الدول
نحن ايضا بالنسبه الى سحر من
هنا نعتبروهم
رهائن دوله ليسوا همم
جواسيس
فنرفود هذا همم هذه العباره وهذا التعريف
كما جدد باتريس باولي موقف فرنسا الرافض
لاستخدام العنف من قبل النظام الايراني ضد
المتظاهرين وعمليات الاعدام التي تنفيذها
سلطات النظام ضد عدد من المحتجر
ملف همم العنف القمع العنيف
ضد المتظاهرين الايرانيين المدنيين
السلميين
فنحن ندين هذا القمر اذا
نتمم ونحن ايضا ندين اللجوء الى عقوبه
الاعدام
افراد البيت الابيض في بيان الله انه من
الواجب مواجهه اجهزه ايران للقمع والارهاب
العابر للحدود وضح البيان ان النظام
الايراني
الولايات المتحده لن تسمح لايران بخنق
المعارضه سلبيه عبر الارهاب
ايضا في الملف الايراني كشفت منظمه حقوق
الانسان الايرانيه عن وصول عدد من
المحتجين الذين يواجهون خطر الاعدام الى
اكثر من 100 متظاهر المنظمه التي تتخذ من
اوسلو مقر لها كشفتنا ايران اعدمت مالا
يقل عن 55 شخصا في يناير الجاري وحده
37 محتجا اعدموا بتهمم تتعلق بالمخدرات في
محاكمات تفتقر للقواعد العادله بحسب وصفها
كشفت منظمه حقوق الانسان الايرانيه ايضا
عن مقتل نحو 500
طلبت منظمه العفو الدوليه ايران بالغاء
احكام الاعدام الصادره ضد ثلاثه محتاجين
قالت انهم تعرضوا لتعذيب وحشي واضافت
المنظمه في بيان لها انه على سلطات
الايرانيه الغاء احكام الادانه واحكام
الاعدام الصادره بحق الشبان واسقاط جميع
التهم المتعلقه بمشاركه مسلميه في
الاحتجاجات
يعتبر وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه السابق
وانا النظام الايراني الذي اسسه الخميني
تنظيم الارهابي بهيئه دوله
اللبناني والحوثيين لتحقيق اجنده توسعيه
في المنطقه
ارهابيه مثل القاعده التي يقع معقلها
الرئيسي في طهران وليس افغانستان
في بغداد مطلع العام 2020 من قبل الرئيس
السابق ترامب ومسؤولين في ادارهته مشيرا
الى ان الوقت قد حان للضغط على الزناد
وانهاء العمليات الارهابيه الايراني
ايضا في هذه النشره ولكن بعد الفاصل
عوده الهدوء الى المستوطنه النبي يعقوب
بعد هجوم الداء الى مقتل ثمانيه اسرائيليه
اهلا بكم من جديد فادوا براسل العربيه
بالقدس بعوده الهدوء الى مستوطنه النبي
يعقوب فيما قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو ان قرارات اتخذت للرد على
الهجوم الذي ادى الى مقتل ثمانيه اشخاص في
اطلاق نار
الشرطه الاسرائيليه قالت ان المنفذ يبلغ
من العمر 21 عاما كما داهمت منزل عائلته
وقامت باعتقاله والده جانبه شدد وزير
الامن القومي الاسرائيليه مره بن غفير على
رد الفوريه على هجوم المستوطنه النبي
جاء غداه مقتل 10 فلسطينيه
نحن في حي بيت حنينا شمال القدس المحتله
على مرمى حجر من مكان العمليه التي جرت في
مستوطنه النبي يعقوب هنا المنفذ دخل من
هذه المنطقه تماما تجاه المستوطنه وصل الى
المنطقه
القريبه وفتح النار عمليا بعد ان ترجع من
السياره على مستوطنين قتل على الاقل
ثمانيه واصاب اخرين ومن ثم حاول العوده
الى حي بيت حنينا الى المنطقه العربيه
يمكن ان نرى السياره ما تزال مركونه بعد
ان اشتبك هناك مع قوات من الشرطه
الاسرائيليه التي صارعت الى اغلاق المكان
الذي تحول الى محج للسياسيين بنيامين
نتنياه وصله وكذا ايضا وزير الامن همم
القومي الاسرائيلي المتطرف هناك اجراءات
امنيه اسرائيليه صارمه همم اتخذت في القدس
الشرقيه المح وكذا ايضا في الضفه الغربيه
خشيه من ان تستمر العمليات الفرديه كالتي
تمت في هذه المنطقه ان تكون هناك موجه
علما ان لا قبل تقريبا لاسرائيل لوقف هذه
العمليات لانها لا تملك معلومات
استخباراتيه بشانها عاده زياد حلبي
العربيه بيت حنينا شمال القدس المحتله
حقوق
الايرانيه نقلت مدربين ايرانيين وعناصر من
ميليشيا حزب الله اللبنانيه من دمشق الى
مدينه دير الزور عبر طائره شحن
انطلقت من مطار دمشق ووضح المرصد السوري
ان الطائره
1525 شخصا تلقوه تدريبات على يد ميليشيا
حزب الله اللبناني في محيط دمشق
تابعا للمليشيات الايرانيه وصلوا الى
مدينه البوكمال
الشرقي لتلقي تدريبات خاصه الايراني
شغل الخارجيه في مجلس النواب الامريكي
اجراء تصوير شهر المقبل على مشروع القانون
اللي حضر استخدام تطبيق تيك توك في
الولايات المتحده
القرار الذي سيمكن البيت الابيض من حضر
تيك توك بشكل قانوني بسبب تاثيره على
الامن القومي
الحصول على المعلومات من خلال الهواتف في
الولايات المتحده
لانتهاك امن البيانات خاصه وان تطبيق لديه
اكثر من 100 مليون مستخدم في الولايات
المتحده
كشفت صحيفه نيويورك نقل عن تقرير البنكي
ان بنك مورجان ثاني فرض غرامات تزيد عن
مليون دولار على موظفيه بسبب اشاره
استخدام تطبيق واتساب وتطبيقات اخرى
لاجراء اعمال الرسميه كما وافق البنك على
دفع 200 مليون دولار للهيات التنظيميه
الفيدراليه بسبب الاستقدام المفرط لواتساب
داخل الصناعه المصرفيه وفي اواخر 2020
بين المديرين التنفيذيين في اداره تداول
السلاح
وبارك بسبب انتهائكهما اللوائح الاداريه
حول استخدام ادوات الاتصال الخارجيه في ما
فائده
ان الغرامات التي ستفرض على مستخدم
من الدولارات الى اكثر من مليون دولار
اعتمادا على مدى الانتهاك وكانت هيئه
الاوراق الماليه قد فرضت خرابات على سته
عشره شركه ماليه بينها بنوك عالميه كبرى
بلغت مليارا و800 مليون دولار بعد ناقش
الموظفون الصفقات والاعمال على اجهزهم
وتطبيقاتهم الشخصيه
اعلنت الحمله الانتخابيه للرئيس الامريكيه
السابقه ترامب ان ترامب سيظهر امام
الجمهور اليوم في الثامن او يوم 28 يناير
في اطار لخوض الانتخابات الرئاسيه في 20
ظهور قد يكون بدايه او نهايه
لمسيرته السياسيه
[موسيقى]
السابق دونالد ترامب قاب قوسين او ادنى
اما من نهايه الماساويه او نقله النوعيه
في حياته السياسيه بعد ان خرج ترامب من
الانتخابات النصفيه نوفمبر الماضي بجراح
لم تندمل بخساره عدد من المرشحين
الجمهوريين الذين دعمهم يطلق حملته
الرئاسيه للعام 24 بمخوف من تكرار ذات
السيناري والمخيب لامال مناصره ترامب
معركه ترامب السياسيه تبدا من ولايه مهاجر
حيث يختبر الرئيس الامريكي السابق قوته
كمرشحين في خطاب امام مئات القاده
الجمهوريين
ليتوجهها بعدها لولايه سوف كارولينا وهي
التي ساعدت في تمهيد طريقه ليصبح مرشح
لحزب الجمهوريه في عام 2016 لكنها خذلته
عام 2020 حين ترشح للرئاسه احد اهم اعمده
ذلك التاييد هو السنه الجمهوري الانستغرام
الى جانب الحكم الجمهوريه مصر والنائب
الجمهوريه المنتخب حديثا راس الفريف لكن
في الوقت نفسه ستغيب اسماء العديد من
الجمهوريين البارزين احدهم هو المدعي
العام للولايه اهلا ويلسون وهو مع اسماء
جمهوريه اخرى ترغب في البقاء على الحياد
بعيدا عن الدراما السياسيه والجدل الذي
يلاحق ترامب شبكه سين انا الامريكيه ترى
بان الاحداث المتسارعه على الساحه
السياسيه وظهوره وثائقي سريه حكوميه في
منزل بايدن وكذلك في منزل النائب السابق
لترامب مايك برنس
ان الانتخابات الرئاسيه عام 2024 لن تكون
مجرده تصويت على من يرغب الجمهور بان يكون
رئيسا للولايات المتحده بل سيتحول لتصويت
حول من يريد الجمهور سجنا اهو الرئيس
الحالي
ام الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب حمزه
العربيه
دخلت تونس مرحله الصوت الانتخابي قبل بدء
الاقتراع صباح يوم الاحد وذلك لاستكمال
الانتخابات التشريعيه في دورها الثاني
المخصصه لتعليق برامج المترشحين
للانتخابات التشريعيه في دورها الثاني او
تكاد هيئه الانتخابات تقول انها وفرت كل
ظروف لوجستيه والبشريه لانجاح الاستحقاق
الانتخابيه اما منظمات المجتمع المدنيه
فتعيب على المسار بعد التسرع في الاجراءات
واداره العمليه المشكله الانتخابات
للانتخابات
هم اكثر من 700 منهم 455
45 سنه سامحوني ملاحقه
ومع اقتراب يوم الاقتراع بقي الشارع
منشغلا بظروف البلاد الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه واختلفت الاراء فيه حول اهميه
الانتخابات التشريعيه في وقت يؤكد
المتابعون اهميه تركيز البرلمان الجديد في
القطع مع المنظومه القديمه
والجوج الجديده
في اجل الاقصى بدايه شهر مارس اداري
المقبل
تصحيح الاوضاع في البلاد وتركيز الجمهوريه
الجديده وليد عبد الله العربيه
تونس العالم
يه
احتجاجات مستمره في ايران
والاعتقالات التعسفيه بحق المتظاهرين
البيت الابيض
المزيد بعد قليل على شاشه العربيه فالى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]